Have you ever participated in a controversy where you were right?
Despite all your eloquent arguments
The facts are supportive of you, but you have not been able to convince anyone.
Is it an effective way
To impress someone and change his mind?
First and foremost inhibitors, which you should accept
Is that these facts do not convince people, especially if they are convinced of another opinion in advance.
All of us wish to believe that
Any information or reliable study will convince us in any discussion
However, successive studies show that some of the facts are incompatible with our beliefs
Makes our brains happy to ignore those facts or to simply dismiss them
In one study, scientists asked people whether they thought humans were responsible for climate change
They then categorized them as supporters and deniers.
They then told some of them that the scientists had reviewed the data and found that
Future predictions are much worse than before
While others were told that the situation was not as bad as we expected.
However, these facts had important implications for their beliefs.
People who do not believe in climate change are told that the situation could get worse
They completely ignored these facts and their views were not affected.
If they were told that the situation was not as bad as expected
Their beliefs tend more towards this perception.
The same goes for those who believe in climate change.
If they are told that things will get worse
They held more to their belief,
If they are told that they will not go wrong, they will not change their minds at all.
Facts make people more polarized.
It is clear that people's views and impressions can not change once they are formed.
As cognitive scientists say.
The whole thing is related to our human capabilities to cooperate among us,
A skill that is not enjoyed by any other living being
To the extent that human beings have been practicing since ancient fishing and picking up to agriculture and modern computers.
Our cooperation allows us to rely on each other's experiences instead of verifying everything
It is therefore difficult to determine where our own perception ends so that another realization begins.
Beliefs are not fundamentally rooted in our deep awareness of the truth.
This is known as (the depth of interpretation).
If you are asked to evaluate your understanding of something as a water cycle
Or fasteners, or computer probabilities
Your conviction that you know about her is much more than you already know.
Come on, try to explain step-by-step and detail the functions of the water cycle or cloud, for example.
Sometimes this simply reveals to us the lack of opinion and opinions of others to any basis of health.
In one study, when participants were asked to assess their public policies
Such as health care, and were later asked to explain it as far as possible
And the impact of their application
They were quick to soften their beliefs
Because they were prone to ignorance.
How can we overcome these tendencies and convince others in a debate?
There seems to be a need to focus on common motivation
According to the world of cognitive perception Tali Sharot
That is, focusing on common motives and the things we agree on
In one study on parents' fears of vaccinating their children
For fear of autism
I have come to know the facts
Which says that science has shown that there is no relationship between the two, but they do not listen to it.
But when they focused on the common goal of protecting their children
The protective purpose of the vaccinations was clear
To avoid diseases such as measles, scoliosis, polio, and tetanus
And how these diseases affect children without autism
Were more likely to vaccinate their children later.
Finally, human beings are known to have biases called internal association biases and external association biases
We tend to be strangers, or different people from what we are
This is reflected in images such as race, religion, form, and gender.
It also comes in the form of ideas and therefore people who disagree with you in your thoughts
Belong to your external group. Studies have also been conducted showing that
If you can communicate with others in any way and make them see you in a different picture
And prepare you as part of their own group, they will be more eager to listen to you
The opposite is true if you do not look like them.
Find the group you belong to and belong to you and use this feature as your own hub
Now, if you want to put your opinions to the test, or become more aware of opinions contrary to your opinion
All you have to do is search for a company,
A wonderful new company that loves me, uses automated learning techniques
To send you things you love but with the trick of sending other purposes
It will push you out of your selective bubble
It's a nice way to check you out, analyze your interests, your questions, your photos, and your video clips
And then you have to flex your mental muscles
With some purposes that are not normally within your holdings.
It is a very good way to try to see the world at a wider angle
This service is completely free!
You can view the Facebook Chat feature by clicking the link below
Then press the Start button to pop up the chat bar
Help them to rationalize your food and nourish your mind
Translating team translating translate autrjim @